BP return to profit during the first
three months of the year after reporting
a huge loss 12 months ago related to its
exit from Russia
while replacement cost profit which is
the recognized industry measure came in
at 8.7 billion dollars for the quarter
that compared with a loss of 23 billion
dollars in the same period last year as
the oil major wrote down the value of
its stake in the Russian oil and gas
company rosnyeft on an underlying basis
replacement cost profit came in at five
billion dollars that was down from 6.2
billion dollars in the same period last
year but up from 4.8 billion dollars in
the final three months of 2022 and
reflected what the company said was an
exceptional performance in its Gas
marketing and trading on BP said it
incurred taxes of 650 million dollars in
its North Sea business During the period